la dernière fois où vous avez posé un
défilé qui posait la question suivante
si on accélère de façon constante et ce
que l'on finit par dépasser la vitesse
de la lumière
si vous n'avez pas eu le temps de
réfléchir à cette question mais tu es
pose maintenant est à la limite fermer
cette fenêtre et réfléchissez à cette
question parce que ça vaut vraiment le
coup dit avoir réfléchi et puis regardez
la réponse demain ou après demain prenez
vraiment le temps de la réflexion
alors bien sûr la réponse doit être non
comme l'affirment volcan la vitesse de
la lumière est une vitesse maximale de
leur accueil de leur activité restreinte
ceci dit je vais la mettre un bémol à
aux commentaires de vol que quand je
trouve qu'il a un petit peu dogmatique
dans sa position en nous disant qu'il
n'y a pas d'explication physique à cela
et que c'est une loi de la nature
je pense que c'est peut-être vrai mais
ce qui importe ce n'est pas la vérité
c'est de chercher à mieux comprendre
cette théorie est pour comprendre cette
théorie il faut absolument chercher à la
remettre en cause a trouvé ses failles
et a cherché à faire pleins d'expérience
de pensée qui nous permettre de nous
poser la question vraiment est-ce que la
vitesse de la lumière ne peut pas être
dépassé si l'on reste dans le cadre de
cette théorie
le but n'étant pas de chercher à montrer
quelques semaines s'est trompé ça vous y
arriverez pas mais le but est vraiment
déchets de mieux comprendre cette
théorie et il me semble c'est mon avis
personnel et c'est un conseil
pédagogique que je vous donne notamment
si vous êtes en train d'apprendre les
sciences et les mathématiques qu'il est
extrêmement utile voire indispensable de
constamment cherché à critiquer tout ce
que l'on vous dit à chercher trouver les
erreurs dans les raisonnements qui vous
sont proposés par vos professeurs au
mieux comprendre ce qui vous dit il
s'agit pas d'essayer de montrer qu'ils
sont hors on est pas en train de faire
des théories complotistes vous invite
constamment a cherché à trouver des
erreurs dans ce qu'on vous dit surtout
lorsque l'on parle de science
bon c'était mon petit conseil assez
tergiversé pas sans réponse à cette
question passionnante
angot vos commentaires peut se
décomposer en trois types de réponses et
pour pouvoir mieux expliquer vos
réponses je vais prendre
sheldon cooper et leonardo chatr va
supposer que leonardo est immobile et
que sheldon accélère accélération
constante dans cette direction et on va
se demander pourquoi est-ce que sheldon
ne peut pas dépasser la vitesse de la
lumière et pour fixer les idées je vous
rappelle que la vitesse de la lumière et
300 mille kilomètres par seconde et on
va supposer que l'accélération de
sheldon et 200 mille kilomètres par
seconde car et c'est à dire qu'à chaque
seconde il gagne 100 mille kilomètres
par seconde si bien qu'au bout de trois
secondes a priori il devra avoir atteint
la vitesse de la lumière
au bout de quatre secondes ils devraient
l'avoir dépassée en tout cas si on
raisonne de façon un petit peu naïve
le premier argument que vous avez
proposé pour expliquer que celle de ne
peut pas dépasser la vitesse de la
lumière est celle de la dilatation du
temps à c'est très très bien vu de la
part de guillaume cantin et didier mazal
lors leurs arguments si leur formule
c'est que sheldon va gagner cent mille
kilomètres par seconde la première
seconde
jusque là pas de problème ensuite il va
gagner 100 1000 km par seconde pendant
la deuxième seconde
mais cette deuxième seconde selon
sheldon va être beaucoup plus longue
dans notre référentiel et puis surtout
la troisième seconde selon sheldon celle
où ils dépasseraient la vitesse de la
lumière va prendre un fait un temps
infini et du coup il faut un temps
infini pour sheldon pour dépasser vitae
et lumière c'est très bien vu
et en fait je n'y avais pas trop pensé
mais du coup une fois que j'ai vu vos
commentaires j'ai commencé à écrire les
équations qui correspondent à ce que
vous dites et j'obtiens l'équation
différentiel suivante où la variation de
la vitesse va être égal à l'accélération
de sheldon / ce qu'on appelle le facteur
de lawrence donc c'est un facteur de
dilatation du temps et si on remplace le
facteur de lawrence par sa vraie formule
obtient v points qui donc la variation
de la vitesse pour ceux qui créent ces
équations différentielles est égal à a
fois la racine carrée de 1 - v2 sur ces
deux arts pour être honnête j'ai pas
réussi à résoudre cette équation
différentielle alors s'il y en a qui
arrivent parmi vous donnez moi la
solution dans les commentaires je suis
pas ultra chercher mais j'ai pas trop
réussi
du coup j'ai juste fait des simulations
numériques et en fait si on essaie de
résoudre ça duka numériquement on voit
que sheldon dépasse bien la vitesse de
la lumière en un temps fini du coup
l'argument de guillaume cantin et didier
mazel était très bien vu mais quand on
regarde les détails mathématiques
ça ne marche pas le deuxième argument
nous vient de sausseau et vie lvg de 7,0
poteau qui introduisent arguments de la
masse selon la masse devrait grossir
quand l'objet se déplace et alors ça
fouette un petit peu plus précis avec
ces termes parce que la masse surface y
en a plusieurs sens du terme mal définie
il ya d'un côté la masse
gravitationnelle hamas inertial quand
j'en ai parlé dans l'épisode sur la plus
honteuse et puis de l'autre côté il y à
la masse relativiste alors le terme de
masse relativiste est aujourd'hui
interdit en pédagogie
alors que c'est lui qui a utilisé
einstein aujourd'hui on préfère toujours
parler uniquement de masse inertielle de
repos et la masse initiale de repos qui
est un petit peu une mesure de la
quantité de choses en un certain sens
cette masse inertielle de repos et en
fait fixe est inchangé c'est celle qui
apparaît dans l'équation végal mc carey
price the way alors qu'est ce que sont
ces deux masses en fait ce sont des
masses à toutes les deux inertielle la
masse inertielle étant la difficulté
qu'il y a à donner du mouvement au corps
plus exactement c'est la force qu'il
faut appliquer encore pour lui donner
une accélération de 1 mètre par seconde
carré et ce qu'a découvert einstein sait
que la force qu'il faut pour donner une
accélération d'un maître parce nous car
est un objet dépend de la vitesse de
l'objet si l'objet va déjà très vite il
va falloir plus de force que ce soit
pour continuer à l'accélérer ou pour le
ralentir ou plus exactement ça
correspond à cette équation un petit peu
dégueu que j'avais montré dans l'épisode
sur régal mc carey est donc ça c'est
vraiment l'inertie de l'objet sauf que
en termes modernes on évite de parler
d'inertie relativiste de l'objet mais on
préfère toujours parler uniquement de la
masse inertielle de repos donc la masse
inertielle de repos c'est la masse
inertielle relativiste lorsque l'objet
ne bouge pas c'est à dire sa difficulté
de bouger un objet dans le référentiel
de leclerc donc si on prend ce deuxième
sens de la masse inertielle qui est
celui qui enseigne en cours de
relativité restreinte à l'école
d'aujourd'hui en tout cas normalement
cette mas cela ne dépend pas de la
vitesse donc il reste constante donc
l'argument de sausseau et de dire vg
machin chose ne marche pas on va voir si
on prend l'argument de la masse
relativiste qui est peut-être celui qui
a été sous-entendu par sochaux et vit à
vg macha chose l'argument tient pas mal
si l'on se demandait qu'est ce qui
affectait le mouvement de sheldon qu'est
ce qu'il faisait accéléré or tel que
j'ai énoncé le problème juste supposer
que sheldon à cette accélération et je
ne me suis pas posé la question de
comment est-ce qu'il arrivait à avoir
cette accélération est en fait on
pourrait imaginer des systèmes un petit
peu compliqué ou par exemple ils
auraient un miroir et on enverrait un
rayon de lune
alors qu'il serait réfléchie par le
miroir et ça ça le ferait accéléré et en
amplifiant la puissance de la lumière
lorsque lorsque sheldon va très vite
on pourrait en tout cas théoriquement
lui assurer une accélération constante
ça paraît un peu débile ce que je dis
pourtant il ya un projet qui a été lancé
et encore une fois c'est un épisode psp
ce thème qui on parle notamment par mark
zuckerberg et stephen hawking en tête de
lice pour lancer à travers l'univers
donc faire des voyages interstellaires
qui serait pas d'humains mais de deux
robots même pas de robots de juste
quelques objets électroniques pour aller
chercher de la vie très très loin et
l'idée c'est de propulser ses satellites
ses mini satellite qu'on aurait à l'aide
de tel rayon de lumière
bref tout ça pour dire que finalement
l'argument de sauce au deuxième mais
j'ai encore une fois c'est très bien vu
mais en fait ça ne répond pas vraiment
la question que je pose puisque moi je
pose suppose directement que sheldon à
cette accélération je me pose pas la
question de la manière dont on le fait
accélérer et enfin il ya quand même une
bonne réponse
elle nous vient de imane mofaz camille
donc iman félicitations tu es le seul à
avoir su donner une réponse
satisfaisante à ce problème
l'argument dimane ne tient en l'énergie
de l'objet et paille doit il n'y a pas
et qui vend centre massey energy hamas
et marie sont deux concepts très
différentes comme j'en ai parlé dans la
vidéo sur régal mc caraïbes pour
comprendre limite de l'argument dimane
je sais pas s'il a compris d'ailleurs
tous les tenants et aboutissants de sa
réponse qui aurait été un petit peu
mieux ça a été un petit peu plus
argumentée d'ailleurs la vraie formule
de l'énergie dans le corps ça va être
gamma mc carey ou gamma est le facteur
de laurens donc si on remplace gamme à
part sa vraie expression donc on obtient
eux est égal à mc carey / la racine
carrée de 1 mois v2 sur ces deux on se
rend compte que quand v temps verser
l'énergie tend vers l'infini
du coup sheldon qui ne peut gagner qu un
nombre fini qu'une quantité finie
d'énergie à chaque instant du temps ne
pourra jamais avoir l'énergie d'un objet
qui ré la vitesse
de la lumière et c'est pourquoi la
réponse du man est bonne toutes mes
félicitations human cependant ce n'est
pas la réponse que je cherchais la
réponse que je cherchais c'était la
réponse qu'il utilise déjà un truc dont
on a parlé dans sa folle et sa voix la
nonna d'itv td vitesse dont j'ai parlé
dans l'épisode 3 alors après un chose à
dire c'est que c'est tout à fait
possible que sheldon et une accélération
constante en fait on une action
constante ici sur terre ne pose aucun
problème de vitesse pour nous puisque
dans notre référentiel en fait notre
vitesse est toujours égale à zéro c'est
un des trucs bizarres avec les
référentiels dans le référentiel de
n'importe quel objet cet objet à une
vitesse égale à zéro bref du coup s'il
ya un problème de dépassement de la
vitesse et lumière ce n'est uniquement
que par rapport à un autre observateur
par exemple celui de leonardo supposons
maintenant que leonardo voix sheldon
aller à 250 mille kilomètres par seconde
et que l'accélération de sheldon selon
lui est de 100 mille kilomètres par
seconde carré donc si on était un petit
peu naïf on pourra se dire que la
prochaine seconde selon sheldon ça y est
qu'on dépasse la vitesse de la lumière
mais pour bien clarifier les choses on
va supposer que sheldon était en fait en
train de voyager avec round et qui
laissera world sur le bas côté
lorsqu'il atteint 250 mille kilomètres
par seconde après la prochaine seconde
selon sheldon sheldon va gagner cent
mille kilomètres par seconde en sont
essentielles qui était celui de round du
coup il va gagner cent mille kilomètres
par seconde par rapport à world
du coup il va cinq mille kilomètres par
seconde par brown a world allaient déjà
250 mille kilomètres par seconde par
rapport à léonore sauf que la donne a
dit éviter des vitesses fait que ces
deux vitesses ne s'additionnent pas et
même si je donne va bien 100 kilomètres
par seconde de plus par rapport à world
il ne va pas sans qu'il me le mètre par
seconde de plus par rapport à aller au
nord de khar éviter ça s'additionne pas
et du coup on fait sa vitesse selon leur
harde restera plus petite si on applique
cette formule qui est la bonne formule
formule de ladite éviter de vitesse mais
en fait si on est unis utilisent cette
formule pour écrire l'équation
différentiel de la vitesse de sheldon on
obtient les causes sont différentes
scènes suivantes
on n'avait point qui est égal à
l'accélération de sheldon dans son
propre référentiel / gamma ça ça change
pas mais cette fois il nous faut
multiplier par ce terme là donc les
détails des quelques jeux vous
très ça dans mon blog mais ils ont six
lots sont un peu les étapes de calcul ça
me donne l'équation différentiel v point
est égal à a fois un mois v carrés sur
ces carrés le tout à la puissance 3
domine alors encore une fois je suis
trop nul en équations différentielles je
connais pas trop la solution de cette
équation si vous la connaissez mettez la
dans les commentaires j'ai juste
résolution numériquement et
numériquement j'ai obtenu ce graphe qui
manque en fait que la vitesse de sheldon
même s'il une accélération constante
selon lui va tendre asymptotiquement
vers la vitesse de la lumière sont
jamais la dépasser et donc ce que
j'attendais d'eux vous ce n'était pas
forcément tout ce raisonnement
mathématique mais juste la mention de
cette nonne addictives it et de la
vitesse quiconque aurait répondu ça ce
serait couvert de gloire en tout cas de
mon admiration de toute mon admiration
et désolait du coup ils man tu n'as
qu'une partie une très grosse partir
mais qu'une partie de mon admiration
ceux-ci clôt le défilé 2 et pour la
prochaine fois je vais vous poser
maintenant le défilé 3,2 des filets 3
qui est une question de gravité
newtonienne je vous demande pas de
résoudre le problème avec la théorie
d'einstein
le problème est le suivant on a deux
étoiles qui tourne l'une autour de
l'autre une des étoiles explose que se
passe-t-il alors pour l'anecdote il
s'agit de la question qui m'avait été
posé mon oral de l'ena elle est un petit
peu mais c'était un sacré souvenir
puisque l'examinateur était resté
silencieux donc je vais je rester collé
au mont tableau avec la mère décrite au
tableau pendant 40 minutes mais au bout
de 40 minutes il m'a un petit peu
aiguilles et puis j'ai posé les bonnes
questions et puis finalement j'ai quand
même réussi à résoudre ce problème qui
n'est pas aussi difficile qu'il peut
paraître tout cas je l'espère que
certains en feu vous arrivons à le
résoudre
ce qu'elle vous invite à mettre toutes
vos réponses toutes vos propositions de
réponses dans les commentaires n'étaient
pas à travailler ensemble à utiliser les
arguments des uns et les autres pour
finir par construire tout un
raisonnement qui répond à cette question
et 7 que quelqu'un gagnera toute mon
admiration la prochaine fois
on appelle ceci diagramme espace temps
c'est le remettre à saturer à 2 g pile
[Musique]